merci d'être avec nous Henri Henry
Dancelle mais le héros ou celui qu'on
appelle le héros sac à dos mais c'est
pas que pour ça maintenant il aime pas
qu'on dit ça je peux comprendre
maintenant que j'ai compris un petit peu
ce qui faisait Henri merci d'être avec
nous Henri merci beaucoup
bonsoir merci Henri alors on va on va
revoir l'image forcément
d'Annecy et c'est vrai qu'on voit
l'image mais après j'aimerais que vous
nous raconter ce que vous faites parce
que c'est incroyable ce que vous faites
et que vous soyez retrouvé là à ce
moment-là c'est quand même un truc de
fou ça fait ça fait réfléchir ce qu'on
se disait avec Gilles Verdez on se dit
c'est incroyable c'est c'est fou soyez
retrouver signe du destin c'est un signe
du destin c'est il faut regarder d'abord
l'image bien sûr que tout le monde a vu
[Musique]
la tête
Henri pourquoi vous étiez dans dans ce
parc je sais que vous cachez les yeux là
pendant cette ces images je sais que
c'est compliqué et ici aussi c'est
toujours compliqué de revoir ces images
pourquoi vous étiez dans ce parc Henri
j'étais en train de repartir vers vers
l'autoroute en passant par la cathédrale
d'Annecy que je voulais revoir une
deuxième fois avant de partir et
je pense que je n'étais pas tout à fait
là par hasard effectivement comme je
l'ai déjà dit à plusieurs reprises sur
le chemin de cet homme et
avec ce que j'avais avec ce que j'avais
sur moi c'est-à-dire mon sac à dos et
donc j'ai pu j'ai essayé de m'interposer
parce que c'est pour moi c'était
intolérable de laisser faire ça en face
de moi et de voir ses innocents qui sont
ces enfants qui sont le symbole de
l'être sans défense se faire faire
massacrer quoi Henri moi de quoi j'ai
envie de parler ce soir surtout c'est
c'est incroyable parce que je vous dis
c'est un signe du destin fou que vous
soyez à ce moment là
Annecy parce que ce que vous pouvez
expliquer à noter les spectateurs vous
ce que vous faites vous faites donc le
tour du monde des cathédrales c'est ça
on verra non non le Tour de France déjà
en France il y en a un sacré paquet il y
en a plus de 170 il faut se rendre
compte que les cathédrales effectivement
irriguent notre nos paysages sont
présents dans l'immense majorité de nos
villes et nos grandes villes et sont les
témoins de notre histoire
sont des merveilles qui l'ont concentré
de d'architecture de spiritualité et
d'art dans nos pays et que elles sont
souvent un peu oubliées donc ce que je
veux faire vraiment avec ce pèlerinage
des cafards de France c'est invité tous
ceux qui veulent me suivre simplement à
lever les yeux
à regarder vers les flèches de ces
cathédrales il y a ce nourrir de skatebo
quoi et Henri je voulais vous dire c'est
c'est vous parce que c'est c'est une
tragédie qui a mis en lumière votre
voyage à travers la France et je suis
sûr qu'il y a plein de gens qui se
disent comme nous aujourd'hui que ça ne
peut pas être le fruit du hasard que
vous êtes soyez retrouver là-bas et
qu'il y a plein de gens qui vont vous
rejoindre dans dans votre dans votre
voyage à travers la France je suis sûr
qu'il y a plein de gens déjà qui sont
qui vous ont dit qui qui les avait envie
de venir avec vous
mais vous savez moi je suis catholique
et j'appelle ça la Providence que vous
n'appelez ce que vous avez enfin ce
qu'on appelle le il n'y a pas de hasard
j'appelle ça la prune en fait c'est
simple ce qui s'est passé assez
symbolique pour moi si vous me permettez
de bien sûr allez-y d'avoir un regard un
peu extérieur aux choses et on a
effectivement donc un demandeur d'asile
syrien qui a une vie pas possible qui se
retrouve en France et qui en proie à
quelque chose de terriblement mauvais
qu'il dépasse en lui et qui décide de
passer à l'acte c'est au moment où il
décide de passer à l'acte il croise la
route d'un pèlerin catholique qui lui
essaye tant bien que mal de vivre la foi
au jour le jour et qui tente de
s'interposer donc si vous voulez on a on
a un peu un symbole de du bien et du mal
qui s'affrontent et ce que je veux
simplement
à travers mon témoignage montrer aux
gens c'est qu'il suffit simplement de de
moi je le fais à travers les cathédrales
mais tout le monde dans sa vie peut
trouver les choses qui les poussent à ça
en fait à relever la tête à regarder ce
qu'il y a de beau et de grand à s'en
nourrir et s'aper sur moi on se nourrit
de ce qu'il y a de beau et de grands
qu'on peut agir en conséquence c'est
incroyable gilet vraiment Henri moi je
mais moi je vous dis c'est il y a plein
de gens qui se disent on a découvert ce
jeune homme excuser qui est incroyable
grâce à cette tragédie et c'est vrai que
quand ce qu'il dit c'est vrai que la
Providence on est là-dedans c'est à la
fois le héros modeste et puis le héros
spirituel c'est à dire qu'effectivement
c'est pas hasard s'il était là c'est pas
un hasard si c'est jeté avec son petit
sac à dos là face à face à la saillant
Henri vous vous parlez de Providence de
spiritualité est-ce que vous pensez au
fond de vous-même qui est effectivement
quelqu'un Dieu la Providence vous a
placé là pour contrecarrer les dessins
de la saillant faut rappeler que sans
vous le bilan aurait été encore plus
terrible parce que vous avez empêché si
je puis dire alors deuxième attaque
c'est sûr
vous me posez une question un peu
complexe parce qu'il est très difficile
de parler de la foi pour une raison
simple c'est que la foi dans la dans la
dans la chrétient dans la foi catholique
et quelque chose de très intime on parle
d'une rencontre intime avec le Christ
donc en fait à partir du moment où la
personne concernée par la foi
à cette au fond de lui cette profonde
conviction et et cette sensibilité à cet
amour-là d'un Dieu qui nous sauve en
fait on a plus peur pour sa vie on a
surtout peur pour celle des autres
merci et magnifique j'aurais vraiment
qu'on applaudisse très fort Henri merci
Henri merci Henri merci
merci d'avoir été là et je sais que le
Président de la République vous a fait
ici vous l'avez demandé une seule chose
qu'est-ce que vous avez demandé au
président oui j'ai profité de l'occasion
pour lui demander l'opportunité de
pouvoir assister à l'inauguration de la
cathédrale Notre-Dame mais en fait c'est
très symbolique ah bien sûr je l'ai fait
je savais ce que je demandais je l'ai
fait simplement et je peux vous
expliquer pourquoi parce que la
cathédrale de Paris représente aux yeux
des français mais aussi surtout aux yeux
du monde entier la cathédrale par
excellence quelle cristallise énormément
de choses dans notre pays forcément avec
son incendie bien sûr et pour moi
c'était une manière aussi de rendre un
dernier hommage à nos cathédrales
puisque l'inauguration aura lieu en 2024
et en 2024 j'aurais terminé mon tour
donc ça sera une façon de mettre un beau
point final vous êtes où là actuellement
toujours à Annecy toujours Anne prend le
temps de quelques jours pour effectuer
le suivi psychologique médical d'accord
merci Henri et bravo à vous merci
d'avoir répondu merci
bravo
très fort